I'll just ask you this one as I was
written to us what element do you think
is the coolest and why oh I think helium
because it boils at 4 degrees absolute
element I think is the coolest gosh the
coolest ass got be carbon super cool
says my personal definition of cool or
what elements the coolest Wow
I know it's going to sell a bit boring
really but I think carbon is in my
opinion the coolest simply because it's
so common and yet something that can be
as relatively cheap and mundane as
graphite can also give you the most
expensive one the most expensive things
in the world in terms of diamond and
it's something that is investigated by
so many different people and yet we
still have a lot to learn about it what
element do you think is the coolest and
why coolest oh man that's a tough one I
guess I ought to say is an organic
chemist
carbon because carbon is the whole area
of carbon chemistry is called organic
chemistry whereas every other element
put together it's called inorganic
chemistry which tells you a little bit
about how rich the chemistry of carbon
must be we're all slaves to it whether
it's through fuel or through jewelry we
all have to have cob I mean we all are
made of carbon but having said that
although it can be pretty smelly
sometimes I do like sulfur it's an
incredibly flexible Assam it can have
just two bonds you can have three bonds
or five bonds to sulfur in it it's very
adaptable with it's not can be very
nucleophilic and can be very
electrophilic it's incredibly flexible
and I often overlooked but as I say
often rather smelly as well
unfortunately well they're not as bad as
selenium which is really noxious
platinum um I think we use platinum in
fuel cells especially because it's a
really good catalyst
so I like it for its catalytic
properties but also I don't wear jewelry
but a lot of people think it's a pretty
cool metal to use it as jewelry
I thought ants are born have a nice both
and I why is it cool um that's an
interesting question
I think I think boron does get a bad not
a bad press but people do I think it's
because it's got borer at the starts
people do think it's boring but it's not
oh it's got to be uranium it's
definitely my favorite element it's got
lots of different colors associated with
it it is the infamous boogeyman of the
periodic table so how could it not be
cool and you can just do lots of
interesting chemistry with it always
surprises you for me the coolest element
I suppose the one that I'd put on the
periodic videos cool wall in the ultra
cool area would be cesium because it
really is a fantastic element it sort
the sample and it's a really nice gold
color and it looks like a really stable
metal but it's hiding inside this glass
ampule under in an atmosphere and and
you know that the moment that you break
that ampule and you let water
specifically in there or any moisture in
the atmosphere in these it's it's going
to unleash a tiger and it's going to be
a fantastic reaction so for me that's
definitely the coolest but it has the
potential to become very hot very
quickly